There are certain rules
when it comes to movies.
It's always the girl
who survives a killer,
it has to rain during every funeral,
and, yes, the third film in a trilogy
almost always sucks.
And it's not just the terrible ones.
Some of the most critically
acclaimed trilogies
also suffer from the threequel curse.
And it got us wondering,
what's really happening here?
The first thing we needed to find out
was just how common bad
threequels really are.
And, surprisingly, the
hardest part was deciding
what exactly constitutes a film trilogy.
In our case, it's a set of three films
that share a continuous
story, character, or theme.
This means that independent
trilogies like "Iron Man"
and "Annabelle" within an
existing franchise count,
but trilogies that are
continued years later
like "Bourne" or "Pirates
of the Caribbean" don't.
We then took 70 of the
highest domestically
grossing trilogies in the US
and calculated each film's
average Rotten Tomatoes score
based on both critic and audience ratings
to get a more accurate depiction.
The list includes the obvious big hitters
like "The Godfather" and "The Karate Kid,"
as well as a few unexpected gems
like Ice Cube's "Barbershop" trilogy.
Eddie: Ricky?
Ricky: What, what?
Eddie: What the hell do you
think you're doing over there?
Ricky: Hey, look, I'm just
trying to get him clean
like them Gillette commercials.
Narrator: Average out all
the scores for first, second,
and third film, put them on a chart,
and you get something like this.
The first film was the obvious winner,
with an average score of 71,
followed by the sequel at 58,
and threequels at 52.
Count them all up, and 64% of trilogies
had their threequel as their worst film.
So, why are threequels
almost always the worst ones?
There are two factors
that come into play here:
formula and necessity.
The reason why film
trilogies have been around
for so long is that they're
a really great structure
to tell a long story,
with each film serving as a
beginning, a middle, and an end.
This also means that
each film should serve
a very specific purpose.
No matter the genre, the
first film always serves
as an origin story that introduces us
to our heroes and the world they live in.
That's why successful
first movies usually fit
into one of two categories.
One, adapted materials from
an existing body of work,
like "The Silence of the Lambs"
or the "Star Trek" reboot,
that accurately capture the essence
of the original source material,
or, two, fresh, original IPs,
like "The Matrix" and "Star Wars,"
that are quite unlike anything
the audience has seen.
The sequels always tend
to enjoy more freedom,
since their characters and worlds
are already established for them.
For this reason, the second film is all
about heroes facing the greatest challenge
they've faced yet, whether
it be iconic villains
or a battle that just
seems impossible to win.
This is where the problem
with threequels comes in.
There isn't really a formula
for a successful threequel,
at least not yet.
And while sequels can
usually stand on their own
and focus on telling a good story...
Bernie: Morning, partner.
Narrator: Threequels have
a lot more to accomplish.
They not only have to tell a great story
that tops the films before it,
but they also need to tie every loose end
and somehow bring a satisfying
conclusion to the saga
in almost exactly the same
length as the other films.
Studios often try to solve this problem
with a bigger budget to
visually raise the stakes.
But it often just comes off as repetitive.
Some threequels actually
repeat previous successes
as a strategy, like how
"Return of the Jedi"
was really a rehash of "A New Hope"
but with a bigger Death Star,
and "Spider-Man 3," which
crams so many villains
into one film, just
replicates the same plot beats
as its previous film.
Which brings us to an even
bigger problem: necessity.
Trilogies suffer the most
when they're just not needed at all.
Skim through 33 of the
worst-rated trilogies,
and you could argue that about 85%
of those films aren't
needed after the first film.
After "The Hangover Part
II" destroyed everything
the first film did
right by replicating it,
there were no loose ends
that needed to be tied up,
nor any separate conclusions to be made.
But two years later, "The
Hangover Part III" still arrived
in the theaters with an
even more abysmal rating.
So, despite all of this,
why does Hollywood keep
making terrible sequels?
The answer seems obvious.
Money, right?
Well, the box office shows that each movie
in a trilogy generally makes less money
than the one that came before,
but their differences aren't big enough
to not warrant a threequel.
On average, that third movie still makes
four times more than its budget.
And as long as we continue to watch them,
the problem will likely never be resolved.
The curse of threequels is an issue
that perhaps best illustrates the problems
with how Hollywood approaches a film.
Demon: We're back!
Narrator: A good film can only be achieved
with a good story.
And once studios forget that eternal fact,
what they're releasing
at the end isn't a film,
but a product without a soul.